the little diamonds either side are for
my mother's jury collection to make sure
that she's with us on this and this
crazy journey together
I'm very explaining how he included
Princess Diana in his proposal to Meghan
Markel here's a look at how he'll likely
do the same when baby Sussex is born
Harry and his late mom were closer than
close and he's made it his mission to
keep her spirit alive since her passing
when he was just 12 we will do
everything we can to make sure that
she's never forgotten Diana's influence
with a parent on Megan and Harry's
wedding day
her favorite forget-me-nots and white
roses were included and all three of
Di's siblings attended Lady Sarah
mccorkadale Lady Jane fellows and Earl
Charles Spencer even Harry's cousins
Lady Kitty Spencer Lady Eliza Spencer
and Louie Spencer made the guest list
and Lady Jane gave a reading during the
ceremony Kensington Palace released this
statement prior to the Sussex Wedding
quote Prince Harry and miss Marcal both
feel honored that Lady Jane will be
representing her family and helping to
celebrate the memory of the leaked
princess on the wedding day the nonce -
diana continued when megan stepped out
for the evening reception wearing her
famous aquamarine ring just one second
but everything we do privately and
unofficially that it makes her proud and
the Sussex duo has made an effort to pay
homage to Harry's late mom ever since
breaking their baby news in October the
same day Megan paired her gorgeous cream
kerinci dress with two pieces of Diana's
jewelry for her first public appearance
following the announcement
I'm sure she's longing for me so she
could be a grandmother again but jewelry
aside the late princesses family has
remained central to Harry's life and
they're expected to be in his baby's
life as well
according to royal expert Victoria
arbiter perhaps Harry's cousins or an
aunt from Diana's side of the family
will likely be included on the
godparents list
what's more bookies are already betting
on potential baby needs and diana is at
the top of the list
her maiden name Spencer is thought to be
another contender
I think constantly talking about granny
diner in 2017 here his brother William
opened up to ITV about how he keeps
Diana's memory alive for his kid I do
you regularly fit in Jewish hearts bad
talk about her and just try and remind
her that some there are two
grandmother's there were two
grandmother's and in their lives and so
it's important that they they know who
she was and and that she existed and we
have no doubt Harry will do the theme
with his royal offspring as she's
looking down you know with with tears in
our eyes being incredibly proud of what
we what we've you know
[Music]